this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you all for coming and I hope that
when you leave after the seminar will
know everything you wanted to know about
Noah and you'll be charged to build
models and tools for growers at
communities etc that use whether to tell
them what they should be doing so what
is new I Noah is a crowdsourced network
both I guess I'm a starting like two
migrants we don't keep you guys too
awfully long isn't that isn't that
terrible i started a stopwatch instead
okay here we go all right
I'm canceling that and I'm going to use
the ancient technology the place is not
a solar you know one of those things we
need to be out the Sun so I will see
where the shade was getting so Noah is a
crowdsourced Network weather station
owners are sharing their data through
the network and providing us with
feedback and guidance on how we can
improve the network and how we can grow
the weather data currently is collected
every 15 minutes and it is tabulated and
hourly and daily summaries we're
collecting precipitation temperature
relative humidity leaf wetness solar
radiation wind speed and wind direction
and the weather stations of the network
have now optionals soil temperature and
moisture sensors available that the
grower can installed we designate sister
stations in the network so that we can
avoid having gaps in the data if you're
accumulating degree days over the year
and you have gaps in your data your day
denies garbage you're not going to have
of degree days so it's really important
not to have missing data so basically
all this data is used to build decision
support tools for I p.m. and crop
production and that's what I'll be
talking about today a little bit more
boring history stuff for you be pouring
it into the meat of the talk know what
was created in 1996 by Curt pestle to
them at the time was the vegetable IPM
coordinator with the new york state IPM
program he had got who believe it or not
in telecommunications grant so we set up
phone lines and Moto's all across New
York to gather weather data yeah right
what's a phone this is a phone so
initially was an association with
membership levels today it's open access
and we have land greg and grower member
support we started out with campbell
instruments that sensor instruments
sensotronic box sensor
became obsolete today we use primarily
rain wise incorporated weather stations
although we can just data from onset
instruments airports and state residents
so why are you talking about the manual
download yep we used to go out with the
computer a laptop computer and download
we fax the data out messages were
created and posted on Kota phones and
the growers can call those clothes and
get that message as to what the
prediction was for the particular day or
week or today we have 428 weather
station locations in 23 states that are
ingested into nua we have 10 member
states plus individual members and five
other states I gave a seminar on you all
month ago and there 415 weather stations
so 13 more just
this is a whole new a homepage I don't
expect you to be able to read this but I
just wanted to point out some things
this is not the culture
the pointer is not working i'm going to
use the cursor okay so this is the
website formula this blue menu up here
follows you through out the website
giving you access to weather data has
forecasts crop management info etc and
up here I kind of like this this is a
little National Weather Service very box
so you can enter your city state here
press go and find out what the weather
forecast is from the National Weather
Service and now given where we are with
the internet the map saves your location
it knows where you are so that can be
really creepy for some of us who are old
school but it's exciting for those of
you like using the web and having it
seamlessly remember where you are so
that is not advance the slide
this is
so the newest station pages all right
the newest station pages look like this
so this is the ash with weather station
page it provides quick links to pest
forecasts here some weather products
here click click links this actually has
been upgraded you know a lot of these
strange Jones do you go now they're not
going to be exactly the same because as
with any web technology or change it all
the time and updating it all the time so
you can access location specific data
here this happens to be a weather
station that you want to an apple grower
and typically the apple growers will
link you know the bookmark this page so
that they can get to easily this is the
new a map the states that are colored
purple our number states they piano
those that are orange have just
individual growers that are plugged into
new up that are paying a small Murphy
and then the larger google map shows the
icons that are the new up stations and
then the National Weather Service
airport locations so how does new a
benefit the program's of plant apology
ecology well certainly plan to these
forecast models can be developed into
tools to inform management decisions I
cam is all about reducing the pesticide
footprint in crops and you'll see as I
get through this talk how much of an
impact this system has on that weather
data can be used to validate and
implement plant disease epidemiology
models or potentially some research that
you're doing on a plant disease epidemic
in addition data and new it can be used
for power system research and
development so you're just doing some
research on the field of its weather
station close by you can correlate some
of those weather events to disease
development so I'm here today I'm giving
I'm kidding try to find myself I'm
giving this talk for the third time
this to stimulate thinking about
developing a utilizing new ID to benefit
counterculture and communities and to
raise awareness of what Noah has to
offer some of you have the dubious
distinction that one of having seen my
seminar that I gave her soil and crop
Sciences I gave us the Vanara for
entomology last month and next month
should you choose to see what we have to
offer for horticulture all beginning
this ok now I have a plethora of devices
here all right so now we're going to go
through some of these predictive tools
they fall into basically three
categories crop management tools weather
products and pests forecast tools all
these tools are in real time their query
based decision support they have some of
them have built in bio fixes the
bioethics could be first trap catch
state common law for Kali ma manage
torture it could be emergence date for
potatoes for understanding went to
strengthen lamplighter growth like to
know when that promise emerging I don't
think
my lips than that work and they all have
an interactive user interface so the
crop management tools I'm not going to
dwell on here but primarily they are
this is the drop-down list on new up for
these and again this changes depending
on what we've got to offer but primarily
crop load management irrigation and
freeze risks are the three key areas
that people are interested in utilizing
litter dia or whether primes so we have
again it's the drop-down list from the
website we have all these degree days
for these base temperatures these are
based on the models that we currently
have so for already calculating the base
temperature we just basically use that
and calculate that and show the
tabulated degree days for that base
temperature and they're tabulated
starting from four different dates
gender in 10 days calendar day march one
al gore's like that April 1 and a 1 I
think April one grape growers like that
so we have hourly data tables dig Lisa
tables and a degree in calculator which
we just resurrected this year so I have
to share this with you I'm really
excited about getting this back online
it went offline when you migrate into a
new website so basically to select the
degree day type accumulation start date
and a picnic report obviously you need
to select the state and the weather
station location and the results show up
here this graph is it rich initially
hidden but you can get button and it
pops open and if you scroll along
there's a little pop-up box that tells
you essentially the point at which
you're working
it's a forecast of five days past two
days and the current so this is the
degree in accumulation today oh yeah got
cold in September is warm this week yes
goa climate warming and then there
obviously is a seasonal accumulation so
this i'm going to show you because this
is what growers can use these are the
hourly and daily data summaries and this
basically is showing what we're now
calling a Valentine's Day Massacre so
last winter was really mild right mild
but then what happened was around
Valentine's Day the temperature limited
and you can see it got as low as minus
10 here and then this is a daily data
summary so you can see here's the 14 and
the 15th so that's why the sweet cherry
crop was pretty much toast in New York
learning peaches to speak of apricots
were toast so those of you who are fans
was a real power because we really
didn't happen
so now I'm going to talk about the
things that are near and dear to our
hearts and these are the past what has
tools for plant diseases and I found out
yesterday that we have two more plant
disease tools than I thought because
well good so i used to say 14 by got 60
yesterday
so I'm going to walk through the apple
scab model I'm a fruit person and so
most of what I know about is fruit so
essentially what you're going to do is a
mention with the degree date calculator
you're going to select a disease on
apple disease models a state this
screenshot happens to be before we put
the state drop down in this school you'd
select a weather station this happened
to be in if so now is giving a talk in
Minnesota and the date of interest April
29 and you get calculated initially this
map town is showing and it has a google
map and wants you to calculate with the
little dots of wheels filming and the
results show up so at the top you can
see there's a great update we are
estimating this green tip date and it's
mcintosh me to date from over 20 years
of historical observations
agricultural experiment station in
Geneva so we've been looking at apple
phenology an insect data for years and
years of there so we can SN we also had
weather data so we can estimate that
green tip date or you can overwrite it
so you can enter your fifty percent free
tip of Macintosh date here and the model
will recalculate so initially at the top
there the S is for maturity summary
ascospores overwinter in the leaf litter
in the orchard and they mature in the
spring and we need at least eleven to
twelve percent mature aside for score
ejection to likely to be likely to occur
so we know that you know this from a lot
of work has been done on Apple's down
here you can see the apple scab ask us
for maturity model is showing what
is for this time frame again to pass
dates of birth date and the five-day
forecast here so it looks like oh yeah
we're going to be you know during the
apple scab season here goes you can
click on this and it will show you the
apple ask us for maturity chart so
here's the chart for us was for maturity
obviously if it was april one it
wouldn't show all of this and just show
a portion of it but this sorry
so
confuse everybody so this was the date
of interest was April 29 and so this is
the ask us for maturity chart or that
date and down here this shows the
temperature in blue the precip in green
and then the forecast data is in a
different color brown yellow
below the S is for maturity chart are
the apple scab effectual notes these are
calculated based on rainfall and
temperature during that rain or leaf
wedding event and basically the charts
can be green or red depending on whether
there is an event I was accessing this
historically and that's why the days to
symptoms haven't calculated here because
the forecast details at that point in
time were being saved and they couldn't
populate this chart but below the
management information is below here and
it's included here and you can click
here for a pesticide selection tool that
is housed on another website and as the
growing season progresses this will
change and the model goes dormant from
October first to march first if this
says a combined event up here you can
click down here at the office can
infection
and you'll get the details of what went
into deciding to combine two web events
into a single wedding event to determine
infection risk and this is basically the
leaf wetness events log 2015 was a
really
here obviously in the soda as well as
here in New York
next I'm going to share that fire blight
model fire blight risk I think probably
this model the apple scab model are the
two top use models by a low Brewers fire
blight is a bacterial disease that can
kill trees out right it kills limbs
adventures the blossoms the model is
modeling Blossom white as opposed to
shoot white so we want to know when the
first loss of open date is again
historically calculated or you can enter
it yourself and then you can say what
the white history is in your orchard
here this model is based on the cover
white bottle from Washington State
University
when you hit calculate these are the
results that you'll get so you can see
for the date slideshows there was low
risk in the past but currently there's
high risk going into the future but then
is getting cooler again and the risk
drops off
this information defines the risk levels
and then there's more to this model
below and essentially what you can do is
you can enter the date that you apply
streptomycin which is an antibiotic
registered for use against fire blight
and once you enter that date you will
recalculate the risk so if i apply strap
on day 11 you can see that the dress is
wrong now too much lower
so the rest of these I'm just going to
give you some screenshots of the rest of
these models that we have on nua we have
a great disease infection events well
four full boxes powdery mildew and
blackrock there's also a downy mildew
simulation model built by years of
research by dr. Pearson Bob seaman
category of benjamina it's called DM
cast I don't have a straight shot of
that but there's that model as well so
you can see in the past there really was
no risk but it looks like in the future
forecast things could get dicey and if
there's disease management information
down here and the page obviously is
longer than that the tomato disease
forecast which was just recently
realized by a bee Cena who specialize in
coordinator is shown here so this is a
screenshot here you can see
on this side as I mentioned before get
report and then this is the report that
shows up so this is where we got the two
additional diseases because they didn't
realize Tom cast was also being used to
predict septoria blight and anthracnose
some tomatoes so that was kind of
exciting so this shows the results for
Tom cast as well as late like sim cast
and then there's a key giving
information about what these things to
me there's also a late blight app that
the prize program developed called white
road ESS ESS downstairs for decision
support system and there's a link to
that on newest thing you want to
download that the potato disease
forecast very similar except the early
blight bottle is different it's
captivating few days here's the pide key
and then here's the league life like
passive severity
onion disease model was recently revised
these were all separate now they're all
on one page so we've got the botrytis
week right model down a mildew and
purple watch here as well as the keys
that tell you what all of this means
so what is new and how is it growing no
to talk about sort of the inner workings
of Noah we started partnering with
Northeast Regional Climate Center in
only 2007-2009 and they now how's our
planet database they help us to model
programming into the p.i design tools
that I just gave you some snapshots of
they help us with data quality control
provide the urological expertise and
guidance and the nice thing is that
they're interested in agricultural
applications for climate data and they
helped us develop automated reports so
that if a weather station is reporting
an automated message goes to that owner
and they know that that their weather
station is reporting and that has been
really well received I was surprised I
thought he would be kind of ticked off
but quite the opposite actually this is
an example of one of the tools that the
Northeast Regional climates that are
themselves create this is stewards wilt
disease for horn and this shows the risk
of the bacteria having overwintered in
the flea beetle that vectors the disease
so if the temperatures in the winter are
really really
old that the bacterium is killed so
they've come back and then there are
also some tools that they have on their
site so we link to their tools and they
also linked to us and we have cross
linkage thing going on so here's a shot
of what the weather station looks like
this complete with cables software
everything is a little under two
thousand dollars and this is the page on
the new website that tells the brewer
how I of weather instrument and get it
connected in we also have done some work
on maintenance and troubleshooting guide
lines one thing I will point out is that
these are no longer configured with the
week window sensor on the south side
these are all solar power so this week
wetness sensor is now attached to the
rain bucket on the north side
rain boys has helped us with file
transfer protocol software to get our
data into our database they now most of
our stations are connected with what
they call me ip100 so it is
automatically being to be in the
internet to their website brain-wise net
and then we scrape the data off their
website into our system this fall were
developing an API so that we can it
started just in one minute kata growers
11 data rain Wise Ones to deliver one
minute date on why because they have
some tools and products the day
themselves have developed frost alarms
and things like that that they would
like to be able to market to their hotel
and they also helped us develop
different products so this is the
exciting thing
weather station numbers have really
grown I became made of wool in 2005 and
got a few grants to just donnelly
increase the network into eastern New
York it was primarily rich in the
central New York area and then things
got really popular and people started
buying and installing the instruments in
New York as of 2016 we have all of these
states that are full state members this
green mark here is New Jersey because
when Jersey the state primatology office
joint and wrote programming to deliver
their entire oncology those event of
data into our system which was really
fantastic he grew by almost 40 rivers to
us
so that was pretty exciting the other
thing is that in 2010 essentially the
plug was pulled on intercultural I p.m.
funding for new york state and i got my
letter saying that I wasn't have a job
as six months and you're all kind of
bummed out in idea and at that time for
the 2011 fiscal year and you can see it
is the blue bar drops here for the 2011
fiscal year no funny at all was
reinstated for New York at all and I was
faced with a five-thousand-dollar tunnel
so every single modem connected weather
instrument was eliminated and growers
were given the option to purchase a ring
wise instrument so that had a huge
impact but at the same time
Massachusetts and Vermont
we're interested in joining and so it
was like the perfect scenario so I said
okay you can join me to have to pay a
fee and so thus was born fiscal
irresponsibility in Nuala and among all
of us but it has since created almost a
nightmare abroad quite rare although I'm
only supposed to be dividing five to ten
percent my time on nua ooh i'm getting a
little bit more than that as you can
well imagine and we are now hiring a new
coordinator so we were successful
to plug that position and are at IPL
funding this year it was reinstated to
the 2010 level so that was really
decided to but it helped
so this is just to give you all the logo
so you have I know we're moving away
from printed a niche or hieroglyphic
communication in our sort of language
based so these are all our current
partners and the thing that's really
exciting is that the state of Minnesota
and the state of North Carolina are full
members because of the Apple River
substitutions in those states and
probably the biggest driver is the Apple
proper management tool the apple from a
hybrid thing is revolutionary
the new partners are becoming so I've
been talking with the state from atala G
offices in North Carolina and Delaware
and the exciting thing is environment
whether started collaborating with us
this year we're just putting the
finishing touches on programming the
ingestion of their data from their state
climatologist a also have a nua type
system and they have models that can
benefit us as well as the models that we
have they mostly want
and then there's a new york state
resident is being constructed right now
across New York funded by FEMA after
sandy and I mean devastated that's an
ally you want Iowa and New York seat so
we are going R and marking our talks
with them to see that I'm going to get
their data a climate smart farming group
por el new student for climate smart
solutions is developing some tools or
climate and I'm excited about what they
are going to be developing because then
that's something else
provides an additional benefit to our
users and this fall we'll be talking
with Glenn Taylor at interest you've
made to see about getting a grade our
models that he has for apples embedded
into new one our stakeholder priorities
obviously the top one is stable funding
responsive web design for station
locations via the use of the National
Digital forecast database which has
about one kilometer resolution more apps
alerts many growers want to be able to
save their brain tip date or to save
that seeing date or whatever it is that
they are putting in as an input for
their bio fix they like knew what to say
that we are set up to do that yet
do that station maintenance
troubleshooting promoting awareness so
that's why I'm here we had a planning
any among all of our members and out
that came four objectives we definitely
want a responsive web design I mean know
what does work okay on a smartphone
there are some platforms that it that
sort of map product skilled work so we
definitely need this new up premium
products would allow us to charge
potentially a subscription fee if we
were to develop an end user cash and
have a premium side to nua you may be
able to have a subscription and thus
improve our funding base and eliminate
the need for the yearly fees that are
paid by the land grant institutions the
virtual stations that was third and then
the fourth objective we talked about was
to create a developer sandbox this would
essentially be behind the scenes where
the researcher developer could go in it
can create a tool see that's working
validated and then if it's working well
yes to
so what kind of data of the weather data
research have we been up to we did
create a leaf like this estimator we had
to have that for airport locations they
don't have any redness sensors and we
did a little bit of work on this there's
more work that needs to be done on that
but we are estimating leaf lettuce for a
hour with relative humidity above 90
we're counting that as a wet our we
haven't gotten any complaints yet we are
using oh and I should say that the
airport relative humidity is error
corrected because it's surrounded by
target and the bike
the microclimate there is vastly
different from agricultural so we are
looking at data quality control for
precipitation orange alert on Planet
Center is working on this and then keith
Ellison who worship the climate center
looks at the solar radiation data
periodically and eliminate stations with
that solar radiation data from the Apple
thinking tool and then we're going to be
looking at temperature and humidity
we've got a project for that it would be
really great to be able to do research
to compare that national digital
forecast database with our own internal
stations and vice versa there s the
meteorologists and climatologists tell
me that's a really
fertil research and then right now
they're looking at soil temperature
estimates compared to actual swale
sensors they're being placed in the
ground Sgt Products Group do a soil
temperature estimate map for us that we
are planning to implement in a weed
germination model down the line
currently on funded we have developed a
sentence a scale model for apples that's
new this year RM y LOL fat without a
researcher development program carrot
cox and i are looking to incorporate the
epithet infection potential from mary
bite into the Apple fire blight tool
Mary white as a copyrighted model it's
pretty available online but we can't
just incorporate an initiative oh
because it's copyrighted and alan digs
at the pursuit maryland has been working
with carrot on that Betsy lab in I p.m.
got a grant from the art for my ability
Institute to develop woody orbital
insect create tools and the Christmas
tree Growers early jazz about this Greg
lobe Carrie Cox and I got some funding
from the New York berry Growers
Association you know very insect and
disease balls embarking on that this
year a nadie childer has an scr I
planning Brad she is alone
Michigan State University and this will
be on blueberry fruit box if there's a
wish list of over 40 miles I mean if
there's just you know as many research
you guys doing all this great work so
where are the impacts and outcomes
so nuanced transyl transforming weather
knowledge into tools farmers are sharing
their weather data resources through
cloud computing and the forecasts are
pushing the results out five days we can
probably go we could probably go a week
and
get too nervous and that makes these
actually disease forecast models because
they were always called two-piece
forecast models but we only had weather
data to say Oh to them you have an apple
scab infection that two days ago about
that now so so that's kind of exciting
to the owner you know forecast the step
out so somatic does from growers that
I've heard I use the newest site almost
every day early in the season the second
one was a little more denigrating
towards us assume that the previously
been used but the first was saying
before chur was scam free for the first
time in several years and the orchard
manager and who might hell de agua
and when Cowgill Rutgers said that to
New Jersey apple growers reported the
best slimming results ever in 2015
residuals
so i guess i would say that nua promotes
better idea reduced pesticide use to
improve environmental protection better
crop management improved crop quality
and improved healed and certainly
enhanced decision support in 2007 before
we launched the website I've just showed
you we launched that website 2009 it's
like geriatric
but in 2007 when he surveyed brokers
about the impact of you off on I p.m.
you can see that the vast majority
agreed or strongly agreed that new I
helps reduce phrase improves great
timing alert a pest risk and enhance IPM
brokers in that survey reported that
they would say on average 19,500 per
year and spray costs and prevent a
quarter of a million dollars per year in
from Los and these are high value
horticultural crops so these are
primarily apple growers grape growers
and a few onion and potato firms that
were responding to the survey back in
two thousand seven
our audience is much larger and broader
now obviously and this piece I didn't
believe it I went over these web stats I
think probably four times but we are
experiencing over two million pageviews
per here at page views when somebody
spends at least 30 minutes on your web
page okay it's not just a click and are
gone it's not yet this is a page view so
Noah is access to IPO decision support
an IPO is all about sustainable
management of pests using methods that
minimize environmental health and
economic risks we're using that disease
epidemiology insect phenology plant
phenology and crop management
information and creating phenological
bonds of forecasts we are doing pretty
good and fruit and vegetables we could
do a lot better in
and field prob setting of livestock it
was open access real-time vary based
decision support Milton bioethics and an
interactive user interface
we've got 40 tools on a rich list or
station locations and end-user cash
alarms better day of quality control is
for anna developer sandbox and with that
thank you and open it up for questions
so i have two questions the first is
would you describe that the populations
of station owners consist of growers and
airports where r is there another
population okay yeah so I had that
slider to get out so the people who own
weather stations include growers they
include land-grant universities so the
Connecticut University of Connecticut
doesn't matter that's connected to New
all the rain wise instruments are owned
by DuPont so some land grant
universities decide they're going to
grant fund their entire resume and put
in but they do it typically on farms
that makes
can I give one ive one in every county
so they did that and I think those are
on schools or above turf grass so long
that type of thing
there is a randomized connected
instrument at the Arnold Arboretum our
universities
there is a weather station in the
Adirondacks that's really associated
with a natural area but the person who
installed it one in debris days because
they do research on insects in insect
phenology there are the state doesn't
it's so Rutgers Meza net they have I
think three different styles of whether
it's plugged in to their doesn't it and
so that that's another another
but by and large we try to ask the
growers recently we had Champlain Valley
agronomic join us they have 22 ray noise
instruments in the Adirondacks in the
Champlain Valley primarily on dairy
farms and they use the data because
concentrate confined papal confined
animal feeding operations cannot spread
manure unless they have a record of the
weather before and after they spread
that more and so that report was
essential and this guy knows a lot about
rain wise instruments as homicide
you mentioned figure of five predicted
[ __ ]
generalization that i took that means
that
biology on the pathogen two sets of
effective
during that five day curry or the
previous trip is that correct depends on
a model ok let me obviously price
because I was after the tractor I did
not hear in presentation the role of
incoming weather plays in terms of the
development practices once everything
else is the line for Disease Joker right
right so predominantly for the most part
the moments of predicting it is actually
meant so it's getting into the planet
well what about symptom development is
that where you're talking to what about
the infection process and the
development of symptoms well the work
can tell me more than going to trigger
the disease once you have all those
others things slide and I end up on a
four day five to thirty right so
depending on the model the things that
may be lining up could be hourly data
it's the model baby
data some most of the insect models only
need daily they only be the maximum in
the so the weather there only two
instances where we're looking at
development of disease and disease
symptoms one is for Alice cabin the
other is required
answering a question sorry from I just
like doing this point that point if
you've got that information that scene
can occur during this five day period
the forecaster then hires a girl would
be paying real attention to the incoming
letter and that's going to make a big
difference for them y squared absolutely
absolutely adjustable so the growers got
to play a role in this in terms of
making that that spray decision based
upon what he gets from other sources yes
absolutely that's a really very good
point because all of this is just what
the grower sees and ultimately it's the
grower that's going to make the decision
so some apple farms that God is so large
that they can't cover in one day their
sprayers cost a quarter billion dollars
you know and they may only have one but
they need five days to cover their
orchard so that's where the size of the
opera he asked Victor so there are all
the kinds of things
precision yes
we measure I'm sorry okay the question
is do we measure the economic impact of
this program in a systematic way um not
being an economist or what i did was i
developed questions for the survey that
basically we're asking the respondents
to fill in how much it was saving them
in springs how much it was saving them
estimated in crop loss i had to go back
to that 2007 survey to see exactly how
those reported wishlist
so like the developers looking for a
project and they go my brain is it will
be there right yeah I have I am so many
forward to having a new a coordinator so
they can get this wish list and figured
out yeah
I was kind of curious of the business
this is incorporated as a not-for-profit
I wondered about additional but I
learned about the issues of intellectual
property
notice the disclaimers on all sides of
your pages but you've got a very complex
to
property for all sorts of sources here
how that work
okay so that's very good question do I
need to repeat the question about IP
okay so I'll talk I'll start with the
disclaimers because that's the easy part
about the time funding was just you know
I didn't we didn't know it was going to
go away but about that time I was poised
to fully disclose new to university and
when you no longer had fun day I had a
lot more to do than that of what we did
get done with cree el nino as we got the
disclaimers written so that square on
the website in total we'll talk about
things like accuracy of the data etc the
disclaimers on each individual tool
we'll talk about this is a tool and only
a tool and it is not a substitute for
actual field observations etc in terms
of intellectual property right we had
based all the models that I know
at this point on published literature
therefore I don't think there would be
an intellectual property rights issue
there are developers to develop things
beyond new one they'll fry case a point
for life life social supports this torch
now is called micro on another potential
would be the DL cast model we're on you
know some company like along and say to
the person who's primarily responsible
for that research hey I'd love develop
an app for that and that would be done I
have
this point not fully disclosed grew up
what i have done is all the references
for these models are posted online so
the key one or two references for every
model that we have a new up is there
online in its own place it's not
actually with the model so they need in
the future so I haven't done that
and hope
thank you very much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu